It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your host, FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!
You're here from the start!
Thank you for joining us!
Wait, Ruffians!
Do you ever join in?
You know what?
Join us for the opening!
Huh?
You fall back asleep.
Say it word by word.
Huh?
Well, Ruffians, today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
In case you didn't hear 5 seconds ago, yes!
Thank you for joining us for our 158th episode.
Déjà vu!
BAU BAU!
I'm feeling a little more fluffy than usual today.
Well, for those who are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show on every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Now, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you first time?
That's you then!
That's the information for you then!
Did Fuwawa see what episode it is today?
I did, Moco-chan!
You said we're your hosts, but I don't know.
Do you know what episode it is, Ruffians?
What episode is it, Ruffians?
She did!
She did it!
I did!
You weren't listening, Ruffians!
She kinda, she kinda sped through it.
Ha!
FUWAMOCO That'll say it again!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us!
Wait, wait, wait, we have to go back, okay?
We have to go back.
Once again, once again.
What is this?
Thank you for joining us for our 128th episode!
I said it though, Moco-chan.
Say it clearly.
FUWAMOCO
Hi!
Ruffians!
Today is a bit different, huh?
We're starting today off on the right paw!
That is a bit different!
Well, you know, it's a new week.
New things happen in a new week, and today is another example of that.
This time, the Ruffians sent us something different!
Different?
Something new for the new week?
Yeah.
You know, I just wanted to send something to start off the week happy, right?
So I... Happy!
No Pero Sighting.
It's just... A sighting!
Ignore it, ignore it.
A sighting!
I'm feeling confused right now, but... A sighting!
Ignore the text.
Okay.
Let's take a look.
What did you want to show us, Ruffians?
We have... De-den!
Breakfast?
Breakfast.
Pero... But breakfast!
I like breakfast!
Breakfast is good, Ruffians!
No!
This breakfast is...
Maybe not the most balanced vitamins wise, but you know, it's a breakfast for the heart!
Breakfast is important!
Ruffians, you have a breakfast, right?
But, there's a question here, you know.
Ruffians.
Breakfast ni suru?
Milk tea ni suru?
Soretomo?
The Great Perroccino.
I think it's an easy decision, right?
You don't.
I can't Pero.
We'll have the milk tea.
Yeah, you can have the breakfast, okay?
And then you know what will make you something even more vitamin happy?
Vitamin healthy?
Vitamin healthy, yes.
Tomorrow.
Green tea smoothie.
Green smoothie.
Well, it's green tea and my green smoothie.
It's just green breakfast.
It's vitamin happy.
You know, next time you're like, today I'm gonna have a very vitamin happy meal.
You know, oh look at this apple.
It's very vitamin happy.
That's how you can use it from now on, Ruffians.
Yeah, pero not very vitamin happy.
Pero burrito.
It does look very comfy, but from a perroccino to...
He's a whole breakfast of caribbeans.
I'll have something else.
Yeah.
Will you play the burrito?
No thank you.
You know, he just kind of took the tray and accidentally pushed it forward.
Probably rolled away.
Off the balcony there.
Then the seagulls could have him!
Everybody's happy!
BAU BAU!
There's a lot of exciting things happening over the weekend!
And one of them!
Wow.
Kaori-senpai!
And she has a brand new song called Die For You.
It's composed by Yuki Tsujimura.
And lyrics is also by Yuki Tsujimura and Kaori-senpai!
Of course.
And the song is kind of to die for.
Moco-chan, were you waiting to say that?
I was.
I was waiting.
But the music video is very cool.
There's lots of different ways to interpret it.
Maybe that's because there's
Interpretive dancing?
Contemporary dancing?
Contemporary and interpretive dancing?
I like the part where Calli-senpai's face is like... At the beginning there.
But it's a very interesting music video.
Definitely a song that you have to listen closely to.
I don't know if you've been paying attention, but Calli-senpai keeps on outdoing herself every single new release of hers.
I don't know!
She blows us away every time!
I can't believe it.
Her singing is so good!
Every time, you know.
Every song is so different vocally and tone and expression.
I love everything that she puts into her music.
Please check it out here!
There's also subtitles in English, Japanese, and in Korean this time.
So you'll have to check it out.
Pay attention to the lyrics too.
BAU BAU!
Congratulations on the new song!
We can't wait to have fun!
Die for you.
I just love the expression that's in her voice so much.
BAU BAU!
BAU
I don't know, I love this illustration.
It looks like a little storybook game.
Maybe it has a little bit of an RPG flavor to it.
We'll have to see it.
You know, every time Ina-senpai has a 3D live, just the world and the atmosphere is so unique to her.
Ina-atmosphere.
I'm really looking forward to what kind of things she's going to do, songs she's going to sing, dance to.
And you know, especially with her guests too.
Yeah, my guests this time are Watame-senpai, Aki-senpai, Botan-senpai, and Bain-senpai!
BAU BAU!
I wonder what sort of shenanigans are going to happen.
Shenanigans?
Shenanigans!
Just imagining their voices together with Ina-senpai's beautiful voice.
You can't spell shenanigans without Ina.
I'm pretty sure.
Is that how it works?
You spell shenanigan with Ina?
Okay, Ruffians, show us!
How would you do it?
Is it true?
It's true?
Yes, it's true!
I don't see it.
You can't spell shenanigan without Ina.
Yes.
Shedanigans.
Okay.
Yes.
FUWAMOCO But you guys have my sweetie live.
It's gonna be happening on her birthday on May 20th at 7pm PT.
Or May 21st at 11am JST.
So we hope that you'll be there cheering her on for her birthday.
BAU BAU!
Fight a tournament!
That was the hololive Animal Tower Battle Tournament!
Animal Battle Tower!
Animal Tower Battle!
I guess the animals form a tower and then you battle.
Yeah, animals don't go into a tower and battle.
I guess that makes sense.
But this is the second time it's organized by Lui-senpai and this time co-host was Subaru-senpai.
And you know it's the second time it grew quite a bit this time with over 20 members.
Is it actually 20?
Let's count.
I think Lui-senpai said over 20.
She's very nervous.
I can't.
I don't want to count.
A lot of members!
Members from JP, IG, EN, The Voice too!
But from EN we have Kari-senpai, Ina-senpai, Alice, FUWAMOCO, and Cecilia!
And we did really well!
For Ruffians that maybe not too sure what this game is, it's a very simple, fun game.
You have some animals, and then you want to stack them on top of them into a tower.
And whoever falls over loses.
Yeah, if you cause the tower to fall, then that person loses.
It's a very simple game, but tricky.
You know, a lot of luck is necessary.
Yes, skill.
Yeah, you know, there's other tricks.
You know, this animal, you might be able to get the animal to kind of hook off the platform, make the platform bigger.
Yeah.
It's not so simple.
It's very addicting in a way.
And we did amazing.
Yeah.
And luck was...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Well, Chawii-senpai!
She won!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
There she is!
She got a snazzy trophy.
Right!
The Animal Tower Battle Tournament trophy there.
But she is very humble, very gracious.
And she said that she'll continue playing lots of the Animal Tower Battle in her free time all the time.
All the time.
I believe her.
She doesn't make songs anymore.
She just plays Animal Tower Battle.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I don't know how it was, but we were able to match randomly with Poruru-oneechan multiple times!
And then even with Kanade too!
And then Poruru-oneechan also matched with Nico!
Ruffians, where are you?
Your chants, you missed it!
You missed your chants!
You couldn't match randomly with random hololive members!
Right!
You missed out!
You didn't think of this!
You tried!
At least you tried.
You don't have a switch.
Ah, then it makes it difficult.
You can't do it on phone to try to match with switch.
Yeah, there is a phone version.
Apparently the phone version is very popular too.
But they are not cross-compatible, so...
That's too bad.
But it was a lot of fun!
So we're happy to be able to participate.
Hopefully there'll be a third one too.
Yeah, we definitely beat Ruffia-senpai and Ollie-senpai.
Not in the slightest.
BAU BAU!
It's always fun being able to play games like that together with everyone though.
You never know what's gonna happen.
Right.
And speaking of things that you don't know what's gonna happen.
FUWAMOCO!
You know when there's call-ins, we like to do call-ins sometimes.
But this time it was a call-in.
We were called by a very unexpected person.
By Ui-mama!
Ui-mama-sensei!
Ui-mama-sense
Ui mama-sensei!
And we were very nervous.
Yes!
Oh boy, did it come this that way?
Nerissa!
We're gonna be okay!
But it was a lot of fun!
We were able to chat about a bunch of different things we talked about.
You know, stuff like that.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Heroines.
It's a really really fun game.
Interesting game.
But it's a little bit more retro.
So I'm happy though.
I feel that that fits Uemamo-sensei really well.
And then we also asked her to educate her daughter better.
Give her a better education.
Because her daughter, Subaru-senpai, told us that there's no such thing as the white school uniform swimsuits in Japan.
That's wrong!
It's a lie.
It's a lie!
So I... So we told her... She should maybe raise a daughter that doesn't lie.
Yeah.
But she told us... That was FUWAMOCO.
That's right though, they don't exist.
Which is not true.
It's not true!
You see, in anime and games, you go to Akihabara, get there, and then...
Uemama-sensei asked us about our socks.
We told her the sock situation.
It was a very interesting conversation.
A normal first time conversation.
Very normal.
Nekoze.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It sounds like a video game, right?
Very cool.
But we're really happy and congratulations!
We've almost hit our 6,000th anniversary!
It feels like a bunch of announcements just went flying by.
BAU BAU!
Really surprising, huh?
This weekend, FUWAMOCO, we are playing a new game.
A game called Fatal Frame.
It's a very classic, famous PS2 horror game.
We are starting from the very first game.
My first time playing this game.
Now what is this game about?
Uh, well, uh, you know, there's a Himuro Mansion.
And we have to find our brother, Mafuyu, who went in there to be able to find Mr. Takamine.
And things aren't going so well, we cannot find our brother, but we have this camera from Mom.
And it sees the ghosts and spirits, so we're gonna use this camera to get rid of the ghosts and find our brother.
Kill the dead ghosts.
Yeah, drive them away with the camera, right?
Are we saving them?
Yeah!
Take positive.
We're saving them.
We're not killing them, we're saving them.
Is that how it is?
But!
Moco-chan.
You have something that you need to apologize about.
There's an apology in order.
Ruffians.
I apologize for my crimes.
The crimes which are hoarding items and reloading a couple times.
Reloading of FUWAMOCO-chan!
Just a couple times.
After the boss battle, because we used too many items, and I took too much damage, which would then use more items, so we will redo it.
Did I beat the boss well enough?
Is this good enough, Ruffians?
Those are the words that Moco-chan would utter non-stop.
Moco-chan, but we learned, and the Ruffians assured you.
Once the game is over, you cannot use the items anymore.
They will not transfer to the next game.
Thus, you must use the items, although limited, in the bosses in the game.
When we are hurt, we shall heal.
We shall not heal with the reload.
I apologize for my crimes of reloading too often and hoarding items.
Save the items!
This is definitely saving a lot.
Too much gamer energy!
This is what you say now, but a couple months ago it was a different story, wasn't it?
No gamer energy.
FUWAMOCO has no gamer energy.
Stories change quickly, huh?
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Huh?
Why did you pause?
You didn't say sorry.
Sorry!
Have you learnt your lesson?
No!
What?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
It's time!
I wanna see a little bit of FWMCMORNING!
We get to see who's the Doggie of the Day today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... That is Pudding!
Pudding!
She's only 7 months old!
That's a baby!
Pudding is very rectangular and I like it!
Pudding!
So cute!
But you know I'm happy to say Pudding is an FUWAMOCO Morning too!
Is that a puppy?
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Pudding BAU BAU?
All I can imagine is Pudding running from one side to the other.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Playtime!
More playtime!
The word associated with playtime is BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I'm just so impressed.
It's good.
Pudding has a good play rhythm going.
You know she hasn't mastered it in 7 months.
Impressive.
7 months and already so stable.
Right.
Yeah well, we hope she has lots of fun chasing after the ball and that you BAU BAU lots together during your playtime.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Well, next we have... Today I went on a walk.
You went on a walk?
I went on a walk!
Well then, why don't you go for a walk this time?
Let's take a look!
De-den!
I bought a surprise book.
What is this?
It looks like a scene from a video game.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It sounds a little spooky, right?
I guess it's not really a desert if there's four more hot springs, huh?
Maybe there was hot springs and then it dried up?
And it's coarsed?
Kinda looks like where we were in Metal Gear Solid 3, now, right?
It sort of reminded me of that.
No ghosts!
No!
I don't think there's gonna be any rations or calorie meat there though.
No.
Maybe snakes.
Maybe rats.
Maybe rats, yeah.
No frogs.
But you're not gonna be eating them because you're not a snake eater.
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you for giving us FUWAMOCO!
And next we have our Question of the Day.
What questions do you have on your mind, Ruffians?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
I know you both like cats a lot.
This is true.
I was wondering on your individual cat preferences.
Do you both have the same favorite kind of cats?
Or are there individual personal preferences for what makes the ideal cat for you two?
Well.
Cats are cats.
Cats.
Kittens are for eating.
Cats are for huffing.
Kittens.
Yes, they're cute though.
Kittens are cute.
This is a common sense basic knowledge, okay?
Oh yeah.
But, you know, I think kittens, they're good, but it's better when they've grown up, you know?
Now they have more of a personality and a cat-itude.
I keep on asking Biboo, is John Cat bigger yet?
How is John Cat growing?
Big yet... Kittens are for eating!
Kittens are for eating!
You know, kittens are for eating.
Snack on the go.
But you know, a cat is a cat.
I think we both have the same preferences, right?
Yeah.
Cat!
I like cat.
Cat's a good cat.
But the best!
What?
The best kind of cat.
If we're gonna be really picky... I like short hair.
You know where the fur is sort of dense?
What?
You know you pet them and they're like, oh that's a cat.
Oh, that's a good pet.
But then...
Fat face.
Fatty face cat.
Yes.
Big cheeks.
Different from squish faces.
I like it when the cats are nice and happy.
You know they're happy they can breathe well.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
A unique looking cat.
Yeah, I know.
Ah, this is that cat.
Yes, that cat.
Yeah, I know.
White kitty's a cute toothy.
All cats are good.
All cats are cute.
Yeah.
All cats are joy.
I love my little angels.
Healthy cats are good though.
Yeah, you know.
Yeah.
Even hairless cats?
Yes!
Yeah!
They're very kind cats.
Yeah, you know they have a lot of requirements for taking care of them.
You have to wash them yourself.
Yeah, you know, you have to put oil on them.
I think you have to.
They have to wear clothing.
Put clothing on the cats?
Yeah.
All cats are tasty.
They are.
They are!
Cats are delicious.
But I want them to cuddle me so that I don't have to come to them.
That they cuddle me and then I feel like a princess.
Thanks for that, Moco-chan.
You're welcome!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your submissions!
We're always looking for more questions!
Thank you for all your questions recently!
Your Pero sightings, you know!
Show us where Pero's been, and then maybe we can, you know, know her, you know?
Just having this breakfast and then...
FUWAMOCO are always up to new things!
This is what our schedule for this week kinda takes a look at.
Kinda takes a look at?
Let's take a look at it!
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Wow, there's still a lot of things up in the air this week, Ruffians.
But we thought that you know, sharing this at least would help give you a little bit of an idea.
Are you serious?
Are we not?
You know, we have a bunch of preparational classes coming up.
You know, we're gonna be an anime voter for the Super Perroquet Party!
But there are also lots of exciting things coming up.
Maybe we can share them with you soon.
Maybe.
What's behind the question, question, question marks?
Who knows?
Maybe there's a lot of exciting things, huh?
But we'll do our best this week!
And we'll see you for FUWAMOCO Morning too!
And hopefully for the Ruffians in Boston, we'll see you in BAU BAU BAU Boston too!
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU DO PEACE!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Grandma!
BAU BAU!
Kitsuneko!
Bakusou!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!